the subject of people getting banned and
blocked on social media has been a big
topic of controversy for the David
Pakman show anytime that we have
moderators block or ban people on reddit
or during the YouTube live streams
accusations start flying about
censorship and we don't encourage open
discussion and blah blah blah so what
I'm going to do for you today in a
second is show you how many people are
blocked or banned on all of our
different platforms and I think you're
going to see that we are so relaxed with
the banning that we do you really have
to get my attention or pats attention or
the attention of the respective
moderators of the different platforms to
get banned we allow so much latitude and
of course we're not a government agency
we are not the government impinge anon
your free speech rights we're just a
show that doesn't want annoying trolling
going on so let's put it up Pat this is
the number of people that are banned
estimates on our different platforms all
right the david pakman show twitter
account has blocked 80 people okay we
currently have something like
70-something thousand followers meaning
that seven thousand would be ten percent
700 would be one percent 70 would be 0
point one percent roughly 0.1% of our
current and past twitter followers have
been blocked only if you are
participating in the most obvious
trolling do you get blocked on my
personal Twitter account there are even
fewer people blocked we have fewer five
fewer followers than the show but even
fewer people blocked about 70 people are
blocked on my Twitter account and again
it's just people that are constantly
hounding and harassing me this might be
the most stunning number of all Pat
YouTube we have 350 something thousand
subscribers and we have had many more
over time because every month people
subscribe but people also unsubscribe so
over time we've probably had something
like 450 thousand subscribers at some
point only a hundred and twenty users
are banned from commenting this includes
both live streams and on demand videos
on YouTube only a hundred and twenty
people out of hundreds of thousands this
really shows that we are not sense
during debate in any way and some of
those people are imposters they'll make
shall names that sound pretty much the
same as the david pakman show right and
it makes it look like we're actually
saying these hateful things yellow just
so people don't get the wrong impression
we'd right have two of these hundred and
twenty blocked accounts i would say
probably 30 are people who were
impersonating either the david pakman
show or me individually or producer
lewis in the past or someone associated
with the show so actual just people
doing regular trolling it's probably
under a hundred people on our facebook
page where we have I think something
like seventy five thousand followers
only 30 people are blocked and its
people that are constantly posting you
know gore gore or racist images or
whatever today they show up and post the
same image 10 times in a day you know
swastikas and we block them and then on
Instagram where I have around eleven
thousand followers I have had to block
20 people that's relatively high
actually for the number of followers I
have but the reason for that is that
since i'm posting stuff like more
personal stuff for some reason i have a
far lower threshold for when I just
don't want to see that crap right like
yeah it shows youtube channel the
tolerance level is way higher than like
these are my personal pictures you know
but i totally get that because that's
not just a professional setting yeah
they're going after your whole life in
your bed exactly right i post a picture
of my coffee yeah i start going crazy on
me it's like that's not what I need on
my Instagram account you know what I
mean anyway up a topless photo and
there's some sexual harassment at you
absolutely rid of that we saw that there
is a topless picture of me on my
Instagram account which had a lot of
people in a tizzy not necessarily a
positive one I should say but anyway I'm
could find that picture i'm on instagram
at david pakman not that many people are
banned all right